factory
sessions to this workshop before we have
the standard problem where in any round
and we might not even assume that we
know how many rounds are going to be
the agent is choosing a single action
from a set of finite k and then
afterwards receives a loss or sometimes
you would think about the reward setting
that depends only on the action that you
have picked and that's the only feedback
that we get so it's the so-called banner
feedback and we assume that this comes
from some stochastic distribution and if
we're talking about adversaries we might
even think that the adversary selects at
around t the distribution for each arm
in this round
and
we care right now about
the talk about the so-called
pseudo-regret which is
the
expected cumulative loss of your
strategy compared to the best fixed
strategy in hindsight
now um
we talk about about about a few regimes
that we have so we have the stochastic
regime where you just assume that at
every round the expectation between
any fixed arm i and
an optimal arm i star is going to be
always
fixed to some gap
and then the corruption setting that's
similar to what you have seen before in
the last talk would be a setting
where there's going to be an adversary
that can outer really corrupt these
losses in every round
and the first one we could think about
is something where the corruption has a
some structure
where the amount that is
any arm can be corrupted over the total
horizon is limited in relation to this
gap
a more primitive
set of corruption would be when the
total amount the total budget is giving
by some
constant c
and even
a more general setting would be to say
okay there is gonna be
corruption but actually every round is
going to corrupt it and just in
expectation over time there's going to
be a gap between
optimal arms and top observance and
finally there's the setting that's fully
advertised
and in this talk today i'm just talking
about these three settings the
stochastic one the medium one with a
fixed corruption and the final one but i
just want to mention that other people
have studied these other settings before
and it's not really clear that this
corruption setting in the middle is
really the one that we should care most
about it's more that it's something that
falls out of the analysis and we can
prove in the setting and that's why i
think a lot of literature started
picking up on the
definition of corruption because it's
just something that we can do easily
here
and
one thing that you might wonder about
whether we need this whole
research at all because the stochastic
algorithms work pretty well and
the counter examples are kind of like
okay we have a deterministic algorithm
and the adversary can just counter it
but in practice that's not what going to
happen and there are also algorithms
such as thomson sampling that have
inherent randomization and people didn't
even really know how bad can thompson
family for example do
in practice and this is a very simple
example of showing that thompson
templing and ucb can fail in a more
realistic setting and let's just say
it's a banded problem with a contact
that you don't observe let's say you're
sending some advertisement email to
somebody you have different typewriters
that can generate this emails and then
you can measure whether a user will
react to this advertisement or not and
let's just assume there's some hidden
confounder the weather that changes
how well is the baseline of all these
interventions that you do but we just
assume that the quality between
different arms that you do they don't
even change with the contact so whether
the weather is nice or whether the rainy
day
the first one is always going to be the
best and it's
the best by the same margin than
everything else so how how difficult can
the setting be for the the vanilla
stochastic algorithms uh that people
have been using and it's surprising
how bad this actually is so if you can
the first plot would be if this contact
is just choose an iid so the whole
problem is an iid problem then you see
this nice
rhythmic curve so the first plot is to
up to ten thousand time in a linear plot
and the other one is the log-log plot
and then down there you see if in a bad
way an adversary is choosing this
context that you don't observe then you
can completely break both
ucb and thompson summing that you have
almost linear regret so you almost don't
learn anything at all
and so
this is kind of giving you an idea why
it actually matters to have robustness
and what people have been doing
is
are using so-called adversarial
algorithms most of them are based on the
concept of follow the regular theater or
sometimes
also seen as a mirror design algorithm
which works in the way that you instead
of keeping some
mean rewards that you have by the
examples you keep unbiased lost
estimators so you have this cumulative
unbiased loft estimator at any time and
you're picking a
sampling distribution that is the best
response given some regular radiation
and then you sample an arm from the
distribution you receive your feedback
and then you do important waiting to
obtain an unbiased loss estimator
this has been around for a long time the
most
popular algorithm is xb3 which is the
banded version of multiplicative weight
update where you use at the regular
radiation the
a normalized neck entropy
another
potential that has been proposed before
would be telos inf that obtains uh the
best bounds uh overall with the best
content for this problem
and
what we see now if we uh plot uh the
result of this that these
algorithms and thinking at p3 here they
are indeed robust to the problem where
you see that
in the problem before the one where the
others are failing horribly
they're still doing well but of course
this algorithm now has a different bound
while the
stochastic algorithms
they they scale
uh with
the logarithm this is scales with square
root t so you're you're significantly
worse in the setting where it's
stochastic and nice but you're way
better in this difficult setting that
are there and so
naturally
there has been this question of whether
you can do both is there really a trait
of needed between the setting where it's
necessarily difficult or can you have an
algorithm that can do both and
by the time that uh devastating
stated this open problem there was
already research into this so they were
already arguing that was to some degree
achieving this but they were extremely
complicated
and they were sub-optimal in some
parameters
and i would say the worst thing is that
the the constant that you just throw
under the rock because you just ignore
them they're so high
that you would need a time horizon
that's
above anything that you would ever want
to do in practice so it's just there's
no way that there's any way of doing
this and then you might say okay but we
always throw this content under the rug
and you just you just attractive reduce
the confidence interval or whatever and
then it seems to work well in practice
but then you lose all the guarantees the
whole point is that you have robustness
here
and
so
let me talk about why this has been such
a hard problem for such a long time
and the reason for this is that
in the adversarial case you somehow
can't get around of doing important
sampling i mean you might introduce some
small buyers that you carefully control
but in the end of the day you're still
not going to be too far away from this
here
and then
suboptimal arms we know for if you want
to be optimal in the stochastic heading
you can only play them at a rate that is
proportional to one over the gap squared
times the time horizon t
to get this logarithmic regret with the
right dependency on the gap
and now if you look at this what does it
mean actually for the
accumulator variant that you're getting
there it's going to be of the order gap
squared t square which means that your
your kind of variance is of the same
magnitude as the signal that you have
because the difference in
loss that you have between the optimal
and the top of the norm is delta i times
t and so all those concentration
arguments that people were using they
they couldn't get it to work with just
this rate they had to increase the
sampling rate of suboptimal arm by at
least the log t factor to get any kind
of concentration going on but then
you're already sub optimal in the
uh socket the case so that's kind of the
reason why this has been such a
difficult problem
and let me walk through what people have
been doing so there are these standard
algorithms ucb for the stochastic
problem that is optimal there is
the implicit normalized forecast by
sebastian bubeck that uses the stylus
entropy that i have shown earlier that
is optimal in the adversarial case with
the i'm just
ignoring uh the dependencies on the gap
but it's it has the lowest uh term that
we know of
and then there has been an algorithm
sapo proposed that's
gonna start with a algorithm for the
stochastic case and it's just constantly
running some checks by doing some
sampling of what it has seen to run some
tests to see whether it detects
with some probability uh
that there was a violation of the aid
assumption and if this assumption is
there then it's doing your irreversible
skip to an
adversarial algorithm which raises a lot
of problems for example once we want to
go away from just
pure iid to this but for some corruption
this thing doesn't work anymore and the
tuning is extremely complicated and this
leads to
this very large
bound so that's not practical a more
practical approach was by my supervisor
who
just started from an advertarial
algorithm and just
injected more exploration to ensure that
the
loss estimator that you see in
the
ethereal algorithm that they will have
concentration but the problem there is
that as i explained before you get this
additional log factors in the stochastic
case because otherwise you can't get
concentration
and finally there's an algorithm there
was an algorithm uh brought by uh cenu
sitting here that was the first one
uh
that
used an adversarial algorithm without
any additional injection of exploration
and was able to just show that it has
some inherent property that's already
taking care of this
and in some sense my my work was to
refine similar techniques that they have
been using
okay and finally what we have been
showing is that by just using the
cellulose and
this uh
then
everything worked out directly you get
the optimal bounds in the
stochastic case and you have the
still the optimal one an epithelial one
question would be any hope to get like a
guarantee where the resale bond will be
depend on the number of adversarial time
steps and not on like say like 99 of the
times that your id
one percent
is ever zero yeah so so we do have
results for this corruption budget in
the midwest you have there you can frame
it like this because the number of
corruption c is obviously bounded by the
number of times that you say that
but there will be one like this
unfortunately the other ones that we
don't have
all right so let's uh start
implementation of why
uh
there it was not obvious that one would
be using this because people have not
used the sellers
regulator at all since the initial paper
and
we were assuming that there's a
trade-off needed and so why would you
pick the one that's the optimal one in
the epithelial case why is that the one
that's in the end gonna turn out to be
optimal in the stochastic case and let's
first look at what xb3 is doing and
there you can see that the uh the
probability distribution that xp3 is
playing from is going to be
some exponential of the negative
cumulative loss times the learning rate
which is somewhat proportional to
exponential of minus square root t times
this
gap estimation where the gap estimation
right now is just the cumulative
loss
divided by the time
and
we know from the stochastic lower bound
that is hopeless to try in the
stochastic case to pull sub-optimal arms
at a rate lower than this one over gas
squared that's t because if you do that
then there's going to be some
probability that you're misidentifying
the optimal arm
and so
xb3 is kind of
always trying too hard to submit to the
best arm and it's gonna completely under
explore sub-optimal arms and that's why
it is sub-optimal an expectation and
it's also why it's very hard to analyze
the algorithm in the stochastic case
because when you do more exploration
than needed then you get a concentration
normally you can deal with things but if
you under explore then
what's going to happen how do you bounce
the thing that has been hard
and now
but xb3 is actually just one member of a
family of algorithms it's called the
cellulose entropy this is the the
formula for the seller's
regular relation
and it's an interpolation between
something called the log barrier which
is the one that genu had been using in
this paper and the xb3 has two extreme
values and the telos ins that we
normally talk about is just in the
middle but this is a whole range of
possible regularization functions now
let's look at what distribution
an algorithm would play when it actually
using one of these
range of
regulators
and by just
solving this minimization problem using
kkt conditions and rearranging things we
see that
the probability is proportional to some
expression here and if we plug in this
middle point one half
then this is exactly
roughly one over gap square times t so
apparently this this uh
this special regulator the one that was
the optimal in that case seems to
when when we would have the ideal
uh
loss estimation would give us exactly
the rate that we have to play
sub-optimal arms of to ensure that we
don't over or under explore suboptimal
arms that was the starting point of why
i started looking into exactly this
algorithm because sometimes people ask
me this and the next step that you
should be doing if you have an idea of
what might be the algorithm just run
experiments
and if you run experiments with exactly
this algorithm you see
it seems to work perfectly fine so
not only does it do has this nice uh
logarithmic curve in the knife setting
in this one harthetic that i hear it
even has a logarithmic curve there
because this setting is actually
a simpler setting that we would now even
call it the catholic setting when you
have this
when you have the gap at any round just
being content that's all what you need
but you also have this it in the
advertising so
the question is
why have people only been able to prove
a bound that scales with square root t
when obviously based on the experiment
is doing so much better
so the next step was to look into the
details of the analysis of what's
happening here and this is a version
with
adaptive learning rate which is
something that we need here
because we want to have the
the probabilities
growing with small t instead of capital
t so we have
uh
we just adopt the standard analysis for
ftrl that you can see for example in the
banded book just for the setting where
you have
adaptive learning rates that is
non-increasing
and then
we have these two terms that you have
seen in the initial talk by hyping lure
which is
the penalty term and the stability term
the penalty term kind of you pay for
having regularization because you're
taking longer to convert towards the
best one and the stability is kind of
something where you pay for making big
changes which getting better when you
have more regularization and we're
looking into the stability term in
detail because that's a term that is
harder this df that i have here that is
the breakman divergence i hope you all
know what the break my diversion is but
let's let's look at uh this per dep
stability term it doesn't look exactly
like the one that what high pen was uh
proposing there we were showing there
because it was something that depends on
the norm uh at the local point but i
show you how you we get there so
the definition of this w tilde that you
have there is that it's the maximum over
everything in the action set of the
current step loss minus
uh
[Music]
at the regular the rate and the
recommended versions from the last time
step that we have
and
the the fragment divergent as long as
you're around
the uh the term wt which
you need to be careful about this but
here you kind of can ensure that you're
always around there it's just gonna be
something roughly the the local norm at
this point
so basically you're
optimizing here something similar to
something that's regularized by the the
predicting term
and now
optimizing over a constraint set is
always hard so let's just get rid of the
constraint set we're
optimizing over uh everything in our rk
and now
there's also what you could do with your
two first kochi schwarz approximation
over there and then with arithmetic
geometric mean you can bound to the
expression by this norm so the last line
is what uh
had been showing you in one of the
introductory talks
and now the problem here is when you
this is not good enough because when you
actually plug in the expectation over
this this the norm that you see down
there is going to scale in each
dimension with the probability to the
three half
your loss estimator is one over the
current probability if you take the
expectation you get the sum over the
square root
of the uh current uh probability you
play and even in the best case
uh when everything is concentrated just
on one single action this term is
already as large as one over square root
t
so if you sum this overall time steps
you're ending up with the bound of
square root t
on the other hand the worst case that
you have if the
distribution is uniform you get a square
root k over square root t which leads
you to the optimal electrical bound now
the question is which step in this whole
analysis is not tight because we know
from the experiments in the
stochasticate it's not tight so
something must be wrong there so you
might assume that maybe it's a cautious
what step because that's kind of a very
worst case bound that you can get or
maybe it's the arabic geometric mean but
actually because you have this
maximization step in front these things
are actually tied here there's nothing
you can gain the point where you lose is
when you do the change from the
optimization problem from the constraint
set to the unconstrained set that is
where actually things suddenly are not
where the things have not been tied so
what can you do on the step instead to
make it tighter
well the idea is that you basically use
something similar to a lagrangian
approach so
because
this thing right now is in the simplex
that would mean that whatever you would
add to the loss estimator that it's a
constant vector
it wouldn't change the
the optimization problem at all because
then you just add a zero there because
both wt and v are in the simplex
so what that's exactly what we would be
doing here so instead of just taking the
maximization about the term that we had
before we're adding some constant of a
vector that has just all the one values
there and
this is kind of if you optimize now but
c that would be equivalent to solving
the constraint problem you need to be a
bit careful that you can't set c too
high or otherwise this first step that
you're doing here from the bracket
divergence to this normal approximation
would break but
let's just assume that this is fine for
now and what what can you do with adding
this term and what it turned out that
what you can do
and you can't do more unfortunately is
that you can in the summer you had
earlier the sum over
all the probabilities you can cancel out
one term
the way you do this for example is to
just say okay i have my one that i want
to cancel out if
this one was the one that was played i
just
remove
so first of all i could say if the one
that i want to remove if the probability
is smaller than one half then i can
bound it by some constant factor of this
sum anyway so i only need to care about
the case where the one i want to remove
is going to be very large but if it's
large then the
loss estimator that i have is going to
be smaller when this one is picked and
then i just set c to the value that i
cancel that one out and then
by just doing this argument i is
relatively easy to see that i can always
eliminate one if you're a bit more fancy
and you just try to do this approach of
really optimizing c based on the current
arm at every time step you still don't
get anything much better you just maybe
get better constant
and
now
let's continue with this so let's just
assume the other term that we have seen
the penalty term you can do the same
thing there is fairly easy so i don't
show you how but there you can exactly
do the same thing you can remove one
contribution of one arm
now
what have you gained here i mean you
still don't really know how to bound
things right because we don't know how
it's actually the distribution of wt
looking like that's the hard thing here
we don't have concentration we have
nothing we don't know what this and if
we just take the worst case and we see
this as an optimization problem and now
the solution would be you put all the
weight on everything but the one that
you have removed and you still have a
bound that scales somewhat with square
root t so
well there is some another step missing
here and so
what is missing is that we actually know
something about the regret because in
the stochastic case we know the regret
is exactly the sum over
this probability that we placed up
optimal arms times the gap
and now
uh since we have an upper bound on this
that it was getting there we have this
uh nice expression here so people who
just see this and are familiar with the
technique they might see immediately
okay you just do arithmetic geometric
mean you rearrange things and you're
done but if you don't see this what i
would always suggest people to do is to
just say okay let's see that an
optimization problem how bad can it
actually be
and this is something uh very often very
useful to write down and if you actually
solve this optimization problem you get
exactly to the point where you see the
regret is bounded by the logarithm over
the gaps which is the the optimal ratio
and the look at the case and now we come
to the point where we actually start
talking about corruption because the
nice thing about this whole analysis
like this is that we get corruption
completely for free
other changes is that in the corrupted
case
our regret is
not equal to the sum of the gap but it
is lower bounded by the sum over the gap
by the probability minus that corruption
budget that we had
and now we can still do exactly the same
thing we formulated the optimization
problem we plug everything in and we
just get this term there that depend on
the corruption it's not even linear in
the corruption which is nice and
and it's uh it can handle
so even in the case where everything is
fully corrupted or almost fully
corrupted we don't even need to go to
that ethereal bound but we still have
something reasonable here
and
now you see why it has been so hard and
we haven't managed to deal with the
other setting that i proposed for
example the the case where we have
uh
the structured corruption where the
corruption in the way that the gaps
still are preserved over time so the
corruption
can only scale always with the gap of an
arm
times the time until then
well
this whole argument here that you have
this lower bound you can't do this
anymore so the best that i i know there
what you could be doing
in this
in the case let's say over
t
times gap rounds you have exactly
corruption of one you could
you could just take
this uh this corruption level with
a non-overlapping different sets and you
take a randomization over the corruption
and this is your environment and this
environment is stochastic gonna have a
bound and because it's non-negative you
get a bound for each of them which is
still very bad because then you get some
extra factor but you have to go
completely out of your way because this
analysis doesn't really work in this
setting and uh yeah
that's uh but on the other hand it has
been extremely successful so people have
been working on exactly this principle
it has been extended to combinatorial
semi bandits the key idea there has been
to just
uh use some hybrid regularization that
you deal with different um cases in
there and you have right and then
uh
for uncoupled exploration well let's say
the feedback that you get
is not from the same arm as the one that
you play so you can play one arm which
lost your suffer and you can pick
another arm whose feedback you get
so there you you can get a better post
work by just using a different alpha
value in the solid entropy it's still
something that is different from
xb3 is different from the one is
somewhere between cells and xb3
then you can get simultaneous second and
first outer bound that has iterative had
shown this it's an extension of the
broad algorithm that genu had where
the main idea is to use additionally
optimistic ftrl and then running a
top-level algorithm
optimizing the optimism that you add
in reinforcement learning with
adversarial rewards there the main idea
was when earlier i was adding in the
optimization step this lagrange factor
with the seat and some content vector
there it was to
have an even
better
shift based on the fact that we have
some
bellman equation and we have even a
larger set over the optimization that
wouldn't change and doing optimization
there then people have extended the two
bands with graph feedback which is again
a hybrid regulation and we now have a
new result with banded with delays so
this analysis has been extended to many
settings and then i think in each of
these settings we always get corruption
robustness for free without needing to
change anything in others or even care
about it because we just always have the
self-bounding technique that you think
there
but
the drawbacks as i mentioned so of the
talk already are that one thing is we
don't get
high probability bounces this because
just everything relies on expectation we
don't even try to get concentration we
don't know
we don't even know whether if it's
purely stochastic if it then at least
high probability
i don't know another thing was it was
really hard to deal with the case of
multiple best arms because if i
told you before
i'm eliminating one arm but the thing is
i can only eliminate one arm and if i
have two optimal arms that have exactly
the same loss then
the probability math will be somewhat
distributed to them and then the
stability term will grow with square
root t and in experiments you see the
stability really grows in square root t
the reason why the overall regret is
still fine is that the penalty term that
i was not talking about today is going
to be negative in that setting but it
has been extremely technical to show
that the negative term canceled out
exactly the positive term this has been
done once in 2021 for the case where we
just have banned it but nobody had ever
done this for any of the other settings
because it's just extremely technical
people wouldn't care about it you just
always assume okay there's one unique
best arm and you do it with this and if
you say okay and bandit it works it will
probably work as well but it is just
going to be
not worth it to try then
these other intermediate regimes that
we're showing people have running
experiment on it they
give
we haven't found any um
example where it would break where self
if would not have the logarithmic regret
anymore so it seems to me that this
algorithm is robust in the other
settings as well but we just have no
idea how to prove it
because this analysis is so reliant on
having this per step property and
there's something going on that
you would need to aggregate over several
time steps and we just don't know how to
do it
and finally
one thing where we couldn't extend it is
linear bandits where again we have an
algorithm that generalizes one of the
base algorithms
the one with log barrier towards linear
banded we can run experiment it worked
in the experiment it has logarithmic
regret but we can again show that
in
very
bad cases the stability term can
actually be larger than what we need
and we don't know how
how to deal with it in the analysis we
only know that it seems to work and so
i'm just saying that even though there's
a lot of success with analysis there's
still issues that we
can't figure out how to do
thank you very much any questions
[Applause]
questions
[Music]
i mean you can do this optimization
problem a little bit better where you
can show that if you're in the regime
where t approaches something of t over
log t then you can even improve this
uh terms up here and here instead of a
log t you have to get
or something and so
the um
the bound is getting uh actually better
when you when you get involved in this
regime this is more
the simple way of doing it when seeing
middle and in the end you still have the
editorial regret bound so you know that
at the end of the day you have a bound
of square root kt and the question is
do you really care so much when you have
already corruption of the level of t
divided by log t do you care whether
it's gonna be square root
kt or will square with kt overlappings
you always do
the stability already you do over
expectations so
when you have
do we know the composition
of
to regret itself rather like the random
variable of the regret rather than
so you can
change editorial algorithms to be robust
to the regret itself but it normally
relies to add
even
more exploration on the arms to to
control this variant term that you're
getting so if you
uh
inject something like one of the third t
exploration with the right or like some
effective bias that is similar to this
then you can get high probability about
all the actual regret but you always
have uh bounds that already
squares very t when you're doing it
so
yeah
you but the thing that you might hope
for is having high probability about
when it is stochastic
yes for the high priority bonds uh the
adversary setting uh
the guidelines paper
where he
it does it's opening modification
right yeah and then you can have the
high pressure bonds just for the cursor
settings so
i don't know whether people try to look
into better
if you can set that modifier like i
think that that modification might
actually be necessary
to get
like advanced concentration of very dead
even just for the adverse therapies
so then the question is whether people
consider
i
changing every day yeah correlates away
do we have a solution to this problem
no budget
everything
i mean
this is actually
an example of something that now just
thought under the the catholic that the
even though it got id because this was
done in the way that whatever the
content
content is the relative
goodness between each arms state and
change
and so here is uh even if an adversary
is choosing whether at any time step is
randomly corresponding
there's a decomposition that i am using
at the end of the
equal to
the gap times the probability of playing
this equation there holds in that
setting too because whether the context
is sunny or whether this gap is the same
and so we actually put this example we
can't even prove them
more questions
this this might be a bit of a technical
one but i did
didn't understand something so in your
proof in the end you set the weights
which according to which you sample such
that the regret is minimized right yeah
okay so
you're asking about the step that i'm
doing here
so is this then
through this step then you get the
weights for the algorithm
yeah no unfortunately no so
this is just saying what would be
the worst case weights
uh in terms of the regret analysis but i
don't know i mean the the weight of the
algorithm itself are going to be some
random variables and they're going to
be numbered so this is just giving us an
upper bound but it's just not thought
doesn't tell us anything about what is
actually the true mean of these ways
anyway
next talk will begin at 4pm